[Music]
all right let's go out to Iowa City Iowa
and talk to Riley what up
Riley Hi how are you doing today I'm all
right man how are
you um I'm I'm doing better than before
but but yeah so what's up what's up so
me and uh me and my wife um we haven't
been really been doing too good these
last few weeks haven't been my
best um just found out um recently a
couple weeks ago she uh cheated on me
and uh I don't know I I just my head's
everywhere still and I just don't
know what to do I first was thinking
about rushing into divorce um but once I
started getting on my emotions I started
thinking of maybe possibly trying to
work it out I I just don't know CU it's
also hard because we also have a
one-year-old and yeah how long you been
married
ma'am uh sadly we've only been married
for about six months um but we were
together for about four
years
so you okay so you've been together for
four years and she cheated on you while
y'all were
dating uh no uh Fe feated on me when we
were uh
married so you've only been married for
6 months mhm so this is very
recent yes and you have a
one-year-old yes we have a one-year-old
okay so somewhere between the baby being
born and and then y'all getting
married um she was with somebody
else
um that's the thing I don't know if they
were really like it was like a longterm
thing or if it was just like a she told
me it was just like a onetime
thing
um so but you don't believe
that I don't know what to believe yeah I
don't know yeah I hate this for you
man yeah and it sucks cuz I'm only 22
and
I I I understand in some parts um you
know I wasn't giving her you know more
love and affection that she wanted I
just I don't know I'm just I got a lot
on my mind a lot on my plate so you're
22 you've been with the same woman for
four years you've been married for six
months you have a one-year-old
baby and during a recent discussion your
wife told you that hey within the last
six months within our time of being
married uh um I had a one night stand
with
somebody and somebody not that's not you
and you're 22 you got a lot going on in
your
mind and um you don't really know which
way to
turn yeah yeah basically because I I
I've just been really set on wanting us
to get us you know financially stable
and living the life that you know a lot
of people could dream of
and um what are you doing for work right
now um just to you know bring money on
the table and provide I just do security
I make I make okay money there I I am
thinking about getting a new job though
or maybe getting a second job to bring
more money in but what's your wife do um
she works in assistant Care
Living okay do y all have child care for
your baby yeah okay um I think you need
to work three jobs
dude and your wife probably needs to
work one maybe two maybe if she needs to
be home with baby when as soon as she
can I get
that and this is separate than the
conversation here I'm going to circle
around and answer your original question
here but you sound like a 22y old guy
who the whole world just showed up in
your house and when I say the whole
world I mean reality and most 22 year
olds especially in the US live in this
fantasy world it's not
real right like I want to follow my
passions and I want to have a unicorn
and a pony and I don't want any bills
and I want to live in downtown Manhattan
and a 4,000 square like they just don't
live in reality and your reality just
hits you in the mouth you have a baby
you have a wife you're dealing with
infidelity you don't have any
money I'm assuming you don't have a
degree or a career
trajectory um no I don't have no degree
or anything I the main thing I just want
to be an author okay that's not for
today yeah I have been a best-selling
author two times over three times over
number one twice and it didn't happen
till I was in my 40s and I've been
writing my whole life okay yeah so I
want you to you write every single day
of your life but you do that after the
baby's in bed and after your wife's
asleep yep right now we're working two
and three day two and three jobs because
you've got to get out of survival mode
because right now your head is so
clouded you don't even know up from down
left to right um and that makes the the
when your body's in fight or flight when
you're just trying to survive you don't
make good rational thinking rational um
uh you don't do things rationally
because your brain doesn't want you
thinking rationally it wants you to not
die it wants you to survive okay and so
the way we're going to get out of this
is by slowly getting your feet into
concrete standing on some kind of firm
Foundation here one of that what those
steps is going to be Financial okay the
other thing is going to be you standing
up feeling a little bit more like um a
dad like a husband right and you don't
feel like that right now you still feel
like a little boy Fair yeah yeah feel
like a little boy you're not you're 22
years old you can
vote I don't know if the options are
great but you can vote right and you're
gonna be able to you have a kid you have
a wife you got stuff to do right so
we're going to get a couple of jobs and
we're going to do that today there's too
much work out there right now okay
that's number one number two do you have
a man in your life that you can sit down
and talk
to uh yeah
who my my father is that a good person
to talk to oh he he's a great person to
talk to does he tell you the truth or
does he tell you what you want to hear
or is he try to make himself feel better
at your expense nope he's full on blunt
okay so what did he he say when you told
him that you found out your wife cheated
on you uh he said that I should give it
just a couple weeks let my head clear
well that's a good man then good for him
because you you've you're like most of
us you have had this story in your head
like if anybody ever cheats on me bro
I'm out of right you've said that to
yourself over and over right yeah and
then the idea of seeing your daughter
two days a week
maybe about rip your guts out doesn't
it uh yeah it it
definitely yeah and the thought of just
throwing away four years of being a
relationship with somebody is pretty
brutal too right you love this woman oh
yeah no I I I love her okay here's the
thing that I don't know if yall have
done yet okay and I'm going to hook you
up with a couple of things to to help
you along the way
um yall if you choose to stay together
you're going to have to rebuild your
marriage from the floor up and I don't
think that's a bad option for you
anyway because I don't know that y'all
were very intentional about how all this
happened she get pregnant and then you
were like oh it's been four years and
you're like let's just get married and
that's how that
went um no
I it I just
uh it's just one of those things where
like we were starting to like get our
lives together and stuff and help each
other's passions and everything and
I just felt like you know uh she was a
she was a one I guess yeah okay but I
mean she was carrying your baby before
you got you even proposed
right um no I I proposed to her before
she was pregnant okay all right let me
tell you something about following your
passion you become really
passionate about what you're good
at and you become really good at what
you practice all the time in the dark
when nobody's
watching and for most of us we either
have some insane internal drive that's
just
crazy or we have a coach or a deadline
that is forcing that upon
us
okay yeah right now you like the idea of
becoming of being paid to be a writer
oh yeah is that fair yeah no it's been
my dream since I'm my passion since I
was in second grade all right I want to
give you a stark other side of it having
a book deadline due I turned in a
chapter from my last book on Christmas
Eve I wrote on Christmas day I had a
standoff with my wife in the garage
where she was
sobbing and I had to I was in service us
to a book deadline so there's a life to
being an author on the other side and
there's the book tour and then there's
the managing social media so there's a
whole other side of this thing that is
hard to get passionate about until you
have been grinding it for years okay I
tell you all that to tell you this you
guys deciding like we're going to
support each other's passions that's not
a good way to approach a
marriage good way to approach a marriage
is I love you what do you need from me
today to be well and whole and here's
what I
need and then but I've got to get my
passion time in and get my fortnite time
time in or whatever that's not for today
right you need me to do X Y and Z I'm in
I'm
in and in this world that I've like in
the book writing world in the show
Making world the entertainment world
it's it's those who with this
Relentless almost lunatic drive that are
up at before the world is up or is is
still awake late late late at
night because they can't see a world
where they're not they can't breathe
unless they write they can't breathe
unless they create something they can't
breathe I remember a season when I
couldn't get out of my head if I didn't
understand how a psychological theory
worked so I'd stay up all night just
trying to figure it out figure it out
figure it out all my friends said you're
crazy my family said I was crazy it just
became a thing I couldn't turn off but
you're not there yet here's why I'm
telling you all that stuff you and your
wife are going to have to decide to
build something completely new in
October if you're still together I'm
going to give you and her a pass to the
money and marriage event that me and
Rachel Cruz put on here in Nashville
okay okay tickets aren't even for sale
yet it's it's almost half sold out from
people who went through it last year and
immediately bought um but we're going
I'm going to offer you two tickets and
that's if y'all are still together in
October okay all right that's number one
number two I'm going to give you both of
my
books on your past change your future is
about okay the world just hit me now
what yeah that that that would be great
okay and building a non-anxious life the
most the most recent book is a model
it's a path for you and your wife to
build a sustainable
life okay right now you have a baby you
have a marriage that is hanging on by a
piece of of dental floss it's not the
time to follow your passion it's time to
get some economic security you and her
go see a marriage counselor ASAP we
can't afford that I'm telling you right
now you got to have that right um we are
planning on seeing a marriage counselor
this week lots and lots and lots and
lots of people plan on seeing counselors
and they never
go yeah okay if she doesn't show up or
doesn't want to go that's that's that's
what you need to know she's not invested
if you don't show up that's what she
needs to know you're not invested
okay now 30 seconds here's what
preparing for divorce looks
like get to see your your kid much less
you're going to have to get a second
place to live or she's going to have to
get a second place to live you're going
to have to navigate child support
separate holidays dating again um
explaining to your friends and family
and figuring out with the kid you see
what I'm saying none of this is easy
yeah know it it definitely does not
sound nor look easy I I witnessed my dad
go through the divorce process and but
also staying with somebody who cheated
on you is not easy
either yeah so you're going to have to
choose your heart there is no easy path
forward they're both very
difficult right okay I don't want you to
think as one is easier than the other is
what I'm trying to say they're both
gonna be hard
yeah if you still love this woman and
you think you can make it work and she's
willing to rebuild everything with you
that's going to be showing you her phone
or not having phones turning them off
not going out and meeting other people
for lunch and dinner and things like
that they're going to put her in
positions where she can have uh make a
stupid decision decision on one night
that you are going to plug back in and
ask her every day how can I love you
today what do you need what do you need
what do you need and you show
up right if y'all want to rebuild
something that you get some Economic
Securities y'all are not just scraping
by every second of the
day now you can build something that can
last and continue to sit down with your
old man he's a trustworthy guy sounds
like continue to say hey I'm not doing
okay today
or Dad what's your wisdom on this I love
that his first impulse was I want you to
take a breath cuz son I've been down
this road and it was hell and it caused
a lot of problems for me and my family
just take a
breath it's a wise wise man
there